now according to new research 86 a lot
of numbers this morning of Anglers say
fishing has helped improve symptoms of
stress or anxiety coinciding with mental
health awareness week the former
football legend David Seaman has teamed
up with the environment agency in a new
campaign to highlight its positive
impacts here he is Hi how are you good
morning how are you I'm good I am really
well tell me about the benefits of
fishing why is it so good for your
mental health
oh how long have you got no it's just
it's something that you know that's
really helped me I love my fishing
um you know and I just found that it it
really helped with
calming me down and getting away
especially when I was playing football
okay because
I played golf
um quite a lot and then sometimes I
found that I was walking off the course
more frustrated than Edwards on it you
know what I mean you know and I was like
no this is not working so then I started
with the fishing and I just found that
being out there with nature trying to
catch fish was just a perfect the
perfect timing for me you know I felt
chill I didn't have to go I didn't have
to be out for a long time even though
now I go off with an actual shooting I
mean my tent and on my sleeping bag but
it's just you know as you can see with
the shots here you know it's just so
calm and relaxing and being out there
with nature
you need to have a rod license is that
right oh yes this is one of the most
questions that I get asked okay is that
you know so so when we people say to me
like do what do you need to do do you
just turn up and fish I'm like no no no
first of all you have got to get a rod
license no matter where you are you need
a rod license to fish you know even if
you're in you know if you're on a river
or a lake or even a canal you've got to
have a rod license and it's so important
you know because not only do does the
money from the rod license
help with the welfare of fishing but
they also use it to to to restock legs
and restock Rivers
um help with bankside vegetation and
repair you know so it's all it all goes
to a great cause
um but it's really important that you
buy a rod license because you can get
fined for quite a lot of money as well
okay where'd you get one from
you go to the the local tackle shops or
online mainly online you know I get mine
I get my reminder every year
um you know so that's that's very
beneficial because maybe it helps you
not to forget you know and there's been
some very high profile people forgot
about their fishing rod licenses have
been caught oh dear now talk to me about
tackling Minds how are you working with
them yeah well we you know as we saw
with the few of the shots there you know
some of the lads that came down and we
went fishing up at uh linear Fisheries
um you know and it's just getting the
awareness out there and and helping
people and giving them a little bit of
confidence to speak out and speak to
someone that's the hardest thing about
mental health is that people don't talk
enough and especially men you know they
don't like to admit it um but there's
we're trying to get that message out
there that the more people you talk to
the easier it's going to become not just
for you but for other people as well you
know and it really does help
but women do women like fishing
yeah there's a few that what the life
not as many not as many as men obviously
but um yeah you know I've seen a lot of
people that uh that are very good
fishing Fisher ladies I should say
um yeah there's some very good carp
fishing people around and um yeah it's
something that you can go on especially
when you go with friends you know
because you can take a barbecue you can
take a picnic you know it's all about
growing being outdoors it's almost like
camping and then fishing is a bonus you
know so that's what I love about it you
know you can meet a lot of people a lot
of friends
um and chat and you know just enjoy the
day really
what's happened to the Arsenal David oh
I know he's he's frustrating Jay because
you know we've got there's a team a
juggernaut of a team in Man City you
know we we saw how good they were last
night against Real Madrid
um and I think that's what happened to
Arsenal live with they were being chased
down by that very very special team
um you know we didn't help ourselves
with a few of the results towards the
end of the season
um you know but you know as I was I was
I was at the training ground this week
and we were saying but the the fat
lady's not singing yeah you know
hopefully they might get distracted and
lose all their remaining remaining three
games and then we might have a chance
but um I'm not holding my breath no if
they win this weekend at home I think
then um it's theirs but
um the Arsenal had some you know some
losses that they shouldn't have had in
that game uh at Liverpool when they were
coasting what happened there yeah the
Liverpool game that because they were
coasted to nil up
um and they just took their foot off the
gas and you know then they went to the
West arm as well very similar situation
you know then obviously the defeat
against Brighton the draws against
Southampton on and then there was a I
think Bournemouth away a Bournemouth at
home as well where we were losing in it
managed to get a draw right at the end
um yeah it was frustrating I think it
was just that they're not
they're not used to this sort of
pressure you know we've got a young team
and a young Squad and it's got a little
bit of experience in there which which I
thought was perfect but obviously
looking at it you know a bit but you
know all this experience is going to be
great for next season
um they've experienced this and now they
should be ready and and know that the
pressure is on for them to be contented
yeah eternally positive that's what we
like Wolfie says hi thanks very much
thanks a lot